blicken wir noch mal gemeinsam zurück
dieses osterfest das nun hinter uns
liegt war wirklich eine grenzerfahrung
man durfte keine schwiegereltern
besuchen überhaupt keine verwandten
besuchen stattdessen tage lang auf dem
sofa legen netflix glotzen immer nur
essen essen essen ist für das
durchgehalten haben da können wir
wirklich so stolz drauf sein wirklich so
stolz der helden verdammte hin
andererseits sollte man auch sonst
machen zu den ganzen touristischen
zielen dürfen wir ja nicht mehr hin
der stadthafen von fürstenberg leer
einzig der hafenmeister ist auf seinem
posten und wartet darauf dass die krise
vorbei geht
ich werde mich in die sonne setzen werde
den entschuldung den spenden aus gucken
da muss er sich doch nicht entschuldigen
schönes hobby es waren wirklich
verrückte ostern verrückte ostern mit
leeren kirchen überlegen sie mal leere
kirchen das kennen unsere fahrer gar
nicht wer aber gut
dafür gab es aber diesmal auto
gottesdienste anders gelesen auto
gottesdienst und ich sage warum nicht
wir schlagen jetzt unsere passat
bedienungsanleitung auf und hupen liebt
nummer 3 116
man muss sich zu helfen wissen super
idee das ist auch dieses oster
komplettpaket für zuhause darin
enthalten kerzen weihrauch und einander
zum gottesdienst to go das kommt gut an
kamen mehr idee das wird sich
durchsetzen das wird sich durch das ein
gottesdienst ich habe mir als kommender
star
da ist alles drin weil auch zum beispiel
zum mitnehmen a23 tiefe züge und man
denkt man spricht direkt mit gott und
was aber noch hier guck mal eine flasche
wasser
wie kann ich dann nachher selber zu wein
verwandelt super
nein man muss sich wirklich zu helfen
wissen trotzdem die kirchen bleiben also
erstmal leer und die religionsfreiheit
macht pause im grunde wie unser
grundgesetz insgesamt es macht pause es
ist halt eine brutale abwägung
gesundheit versus freiheit stichwort
reisefreiheit neuerdings gibt es bei uns
ja sogar wieder innerdeutscher
grenzkontrollen
wenn man zum beispiel nach
mecklenburg-vorpommern gereist um da die
kernfamilie zu besuchen ist auch noch so
gerade okay aber dieser berliner hier
der wollte ernsthaft zu seiner tante
doch statt umzudrehen fährt der berliner
einfach weiter eine osterfeier bei tante
und schon beginnt die verfolgungsjagd
später wird er den beamten erzählen sein
navi habe gesponnen
er ist schnell wieder eingefangen und
wird mit blaulicht zur landesgrenze
eskortiert abgeschoben gott sei dank
gott sei dank wieder ein tanten besucher
hinter schloss und riegel
inzwischen ist in deutschland alles
wieder wie weil sie nicht 1832 wenn man
von hessen kassel nach hessen nassau
wollte oder so auch hamburg und
schleswig holstein sind jetzt offiziell
im krieg weil immer wieder ist kein witz
reiche hamburger versuchen illegal nach
sylt zu gelangen
tja nach sylt die landen nachts mit
ihren booten oder verkleiden sich als
handwerker liebe zuschauer verschließen
wir nicht unsere augen vor diesem elend
nichts gegen fliege personal oder
supermarkt kassiererinnen
aber wer denkt in diesen tagen an reiche
hamburger mit rosa auf sylt das regime
von schleswig-holstein lässt diese
menschen nicht mehr auf ihre insel
wenn jeder von uns nur einen reichen
hamburger in seinem kofferraum nach süd
schmuggelt im heißluftballon oder durch
einen selbst gegrabenen tunnel unter dem
wattenmeer können diese hanseaten bald
wieder lachen
deshalb schützen wir jetzt das
grundrecht auf sylt
danke schön aktion bewegungsfreiheit
versammlungsfreiheit eigentumsfreiheit
alles macht wegen corona buch und nein
natürlich wird gerade nicht heimlich die
korona diktatur eingeführt wie die
üblichen verstrahlten im netz behaupten
aber tatsache ist schon der start sollte
ständig prüfen ob es auch mit weniger
grundrechts einschränkungen gehen würde
die polizei jetzt mehrfach wie hier in
berlin demos für eine humanere
flüchtlingspolitik aufgelöst und zwar
obwohl sich die demonstranten wirklich
an alle abstandsregeln gehalten haben
wenn man die art staat wollen wir ja
eigentlich nicht werden oder es und sie
dass jemand aus wie in tunesien wo
fußgänger von polizei robotern
kontrolliert werden
der hat die angemacht ja die beiden sind
jetzt verheiratet
wichtig ist dass wir bürger der inneren
logik von corona beschränkungen noch
folgen können man muss folgen können und
das ist nicht immer einfach
neulich hat zum beispiel die polizei in
münchen das hier getwittert nein ein
buch auf einer bank lesen ist nicht
erlaubt meine hilft weniger lesen gegen
korona ich glaube nicht musste der
bayerische innenminister dann auch kurz
danach wieder korrigieren
trotzdem bleibt der stadtpark wirklich
ein juristisches minenfeld auch in
nordrhein westfalen eine mutter macht
mit ihren kindern picknick im park
die sache ist nämlich so wer von zu
hause essen mitbringt macht ein picknick
verboten sich am kiosk eine kohle oder
ein eis kaufen erlaubt ja logisch 250
euro bußgeld mussten die bezahlen die
frechen picknicker solche regel
verunsichern die menschen schon wir sind
ja alle sehr diszipliniert aber das
verunsichert auch in hessen dieses
zwischendurch man darf im park rumlaufen
aber nicht rumsitzen inzwischen auch
zurückgenommen
es ist kompliziert von land zu land aber
ich versuche das wesentliche mal für sie
zusammenzufassen normales joggen ist
weiterhin überall gestattet aber nur bei
einer mindestgeschwindigkeit von 12
stundenkilometern
was wir hier sehen ist wahrscheinlich
schon hochgradig illegal in köln dürfen
zwei leute im park auf der wiese sitzen
wenn sie dabei 50 sneakers futtern die
sie neben an einem kiosk gekauft haben
ist das legal wenn sie aber selbst
gebackenen dinkel kekse von zu hause
mitgebracht haben sind sie leider
kriminelle auf der parkbank sitzen ist
noch erlaubt dabei enten füttern nicht
denn das ist natürlich ein picknick
logisch und damit haben sich die
wasservögel strafbar gemacht und werden
abgeführt
ich hoffe sie zu hause haben das alles
mit geschrieben politiker müssen
natürlich alle szenarien durchspielen
was wenn das verständnis der bevölkerung
für die korona maßnahmen doch noch
irgendwann kippt was dann
man könnte uns bürgern zum beispiel
angst machen ja genau das steht nämlich
auf einer seite eines 17 seitigen
strategiepapier das externe experten
neulich kein witz für das
bundesinnenministerium erstellt haben
und das inzwischen gelegt wurde
wir schauen mal live zu carolin kebekus
nach berlin sie leitet für das
ministerium die erwähnte expertengruppe
frau kebekus was genau war nochmal ihre
aufgabe das nennt man najin englisch für
schubsen
der bürger wird von uns geschubst damit
er von alleine vernünftige
entscheidungen trifft und sie herr welke
denken dann sie hätten tatsächlich was
entschieden aber in wirklichkeit habe
ich sie genutzt hätten sie gar nicht
toll
und wie geht schubsen naja unter anderem
mit angst steht ja auf seite 13 unseres
leider gelegten corona papiers zitat um
die gewünschte schockwirkung zu erzielen
müssen die konkreten auswirkungen einer
durchseuchung verdeutlicht werden
und da hatten wir als experten zum
beispiel vorgeschlagen wo ich auch mal
unseren kindern ein bisschen bammel zu
machen bei die plagen ja denken corona
geht sie nichts an
die sollten mal darüber nachdenken was
passiert zitat wenn sie dann ihre eltern
anstecken und einer davon qualvoll zu
hause stirbt und sie das gefühl haben
schuld daran zu sein weil sie vergessen
haben sich nach dem spielen die hände zu
waschen
gucken sie ist ja grauenvoll
als wäre die armen kleinen krieger
albträume ja das ist ja der ganze witz
bei der sache deswegen haben wir doch
sogar neue kinderbücher vorgeschlagen
weißt du eigentlich wie ansteckend ich
bin pumuckl wusstet meister eder an und
findus hat petterson umgebracht sehr
schön
muss man denn überhaupt mit angst
arbeiten ich meine wir deutschen haben
noch in der geschichte nun wirklich
bewiesen dass wir gerne befehle befolgen
uns muss man doch gar keine angst machen
ja mein gott das war halt mein
brainstorming in unserer runde saßen
übrigens wirtschaftswissenschaftler mit
drin aber natürlich auch erfahrene
kinder erschrecker wie stephen king oder
rolf zuckowski verstehe und wird jetzt
weiter gelogen sobald die kitas wieder
aufmachen trete ich da auf mit meinem
corona kasperletheater vorsicht
großmutter das krokodil hat eine
fledermaus gefressen lass dich bloß
nicht anhusten und jetzt richtig
gruselig carolin kebekus carolin kebekus
ja man kann wirklich nur hoffen dass die
deutsche wirtschaft diese corona krise
einigermaßen und irgendwie übersteht wer
sich wirklich muss man sagen bewundert
wird schnell an die neue lage anpasst
sind tatsächlich unsere kriminell
ja da ist es völlig aufpassen herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
vorsicht falle
nepper präparieren finger mit friedemann
weise
[Musik]
in diesen tagen ist vorsicht geboten
liebe zuschauer aber nicht nur vor viren
überall nutzen kriminelle die korona
krise aus es sind sogar falsche
polizisten unterwegs die an der haustür
bußgelder verlangen kleiner tipp
betrüger verraten sich oft durch ihre
dienstnummer 123 party polizei um ganz
sicher zu gehen machen sie laute musik
an und wenn er beamte so reagiert ist er
wahrscheinlich kein polizist
auch webseiten von corona
hilfsprogrammen wurden gefälscht um an
sensible daten zu gelangen
auch hier gilt augen auf offizielle
seiten des landes nrw
erkennen sie immer an dieser startseite
wegen server überlastung nicht
erreichbar
leider findet man auch unseriöse
heilmethoden gegen korona ein politiker
in den usa behauptet zum beispiel dass
man mit einem fön die viren im hals
töten kann wissenschaftlich ist sehr
umstritten effektiver ist er auf jeden
fall der gute alte kirche ein weiteres
problem sind selbst genähte masken oft
bieten diese nicht ausreichend schutz
zum teil sind sie sogar grob fahrlässig
ich empfehle stattdessen das hier
karnevals katzenohren sie dumm aus aber
die idee dahinter ist so simpel wie
genial das virus stammt ja von
fledermäusen und fledermäuse haben angst
vor katzen siehste am gefährlichsten
sind aber die scharlatane auf youtube
und co das im labor hergestellte corona
virus war eine vertuschung für die
durchsetzung obligatorischer impfungen
welche man uns aufzwingen wollte aber
jetzt ist es die größte verdeckte us
geheimdienst operation geworden welche
die welt je gesehen hat genau
der geheimdienst hat ihm schon die farbe
abgedreht wie kommt man auf so was
und meine informationsquellen sind nicht
immer die schlechtesten
nicht immer aber sehr oft oder zum glück
gibt's im netz ja auch positive menschen
bzw engel oder engel energien
am besten sie erklärte selbst ich bin
in kandierte engel also eine menge
energie in einen menschlichen körper
ok und was macht so eine engel energie
in der korona krise gemeinsam erschaffen
wir das neue zeit für euch auf ihren in
liebe ganz menge michael und alle engel
dieser welt was ist eigentlich mit der
infektionsrate bei erzengeln davon hat
osten natürlich nie geredet denken sie
da mal drüber nach kleiner tipp es hat
mit dem us geheimdienst zu tun
tipp alter die erklärt hatte er wieder
alles wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gold ich
habe es noch drauf also ich würde den
kanal direkt abonnieren und auf gefällt
mir drücken wenn ich das nicht so getan
hätte
das war richtig stark
[Musik]